I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey there, everyone. It's Angela Kinsey. It's Jenna Fisher. And we are here to talk to you this week about the job. Yes. It's the end of season three, Angela. This is the season three finale. I can't believe we're already at the season three finale. I can't either. I can't either. I was saying to my husband the other day, I was like, babe,
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在做《办公室》的终极重温播客，专属于你们。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好，我是安吉拉·金西。我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我们这周来到这里和大家聊聊“工作”这一集。是的。这是第三季的结尾，安吉拉。这是第三季的大结局。真不敢相信我们已经迎来了第三季的大结局。我也真不敢相信。我也真不敢相信。我前几天还对我丈夫说，我说，宝贝，
Jenna and I have talked for a year now about the show. And it doesn't even feel like any time has gone by. I mean, I think we just really enjoy hanging out and talking with each other and also talking about the show. Well, this is actually the job part one. This is an hour-long episode finale. So we're dividing it into two episodes of Office, ladies, so that we can really cover everything. This was written by Paul Lieberstein and Mike Shore and directed by Ken Quapas. Jenna, do you know it was also co-edited? Not only co-written, but it was co-edited with Dave Rogers and Dean Holland. Wow. Because it was such a big episode. We put everyone on this. All hands on deck. Well, here is a summary
珍娜和我谈论这部剧已经有一年了。感觉时间好像一点都没过去。我的意思是，我觉得我们真的很享受在一起闲逛、聊天，同时也谈论这部剧。嗯，实际上这是“工作（上集）”。这是一个时长一小时的大结局剧集。所以我们把它分成了两集“办公室女士”，这样我们就能真正涵盖所有内容。这一集由保罗·利伯斯坦和迈克·肖尔编剧，肯·夸帕斯导演。珍娜，你知道它还联合剪辑了吗？不仅是联合编剧，它还与戴夫·罗杰斯和迪恩·霍兰德联合剪辑。哇。因为这是一集非常重磅的剧。我们让所有人都参与进来了。全员出动。嗯，这里是摘要
for part one. Before leaving for his interview and confident he already has a new job at corporate, Michael names Dwight as his replacement at Dunder Mifflin Scranton. Angela could not be more excited. Oh, yeah. But before Michael can leave, Jan pays a surprise visit. She shows Michael her new breast enhancement and says she wants to get back together. Jim and Karen leave early as they are also interviewing for the job at corporate. Dwight makes Andy his number two since Andy is the only person who would interview for the position. And that's just the first half. There's more to come. Yeah. Well, listen to kick off this finale episode. We have a surprise guest. We're so excited. Writer, Toby himself, Paul Lieberstein.
第一部分。迈克尔在出发去面试之前，坚信自己已经在总公司获得了一份新工作，他任命德怀特为他在邓德米夫林斯克兰分公司的接替者。安吉拉兴奋极了。哦，是的。但就在迈克尔离开之前，简进行了突击拜访。她向迈克尔展示了她新的丰胸成果，并表示她想复合。吉姆和凯伦提前离开，因为他们也要去总公司面试该职位。德怀特让安迪担任他的副手，因为安迪是唯一一个会来面试这个职位的人。这还只是前半部分。还有更多精彩内容。是的。嗯，听着，为了拉开这个大结局剧集的序幕，我们有一个惊喜嘉宾。我们太激动了。编剧，托比本人，保罗·利伯斯坦。
Toby is in the house. Well, you know, in the zoom house. Toby's in the zoom house. Oh, well, we asked him all about being Toby and all about this episode. Sam, will you play the interview? Hello, Paul Lieberstein. Welcome to office, ladies. Hello, Jada Fisher. Hello, Angel Kinsey. Thank you for having me. Oh, thanks so much for being on. My pleasure. We're so excited to have you today. Thank you. We were texting and I know you were texting with Angela as well. And you told us that you have not seen an episode of the show since it aired, but that you were going to watch the job today. How was that experience for you? I'm dying to know. It was it was really interesting. I felt like there's moments that really, really shined.
托比大驾光临。嗯，你知道的，在Zoom里。托比在Zoom里。哦，嗯，我们问了他所有关于扮演托比以及关于这一集的事情。山姆，你能播放一下采访吗？你好，保罗·利伯斯坦。欢迎来到办公室女士。你好，珍娜·菲舍尔。你好，安吉拉·金西。谢谢你们邀请我。哦，非常感谢你能来。我的荣幸。我们今天能请到你非常兴奋。谢谢。我们一直在发短信，我知道你和安吉拉也在发短信。你告诉我们，自该剧播出以来，你一集都没有看过，但你今天打算看“工作”这一集。那对你来说是一次怎样的体验？我很想知道。这真的很、真的很奇妙。我觉得有些时刻真的很出彩，
And and then there's like, you know, the writer part of me was like, oh, okay, I think I would have done that a little differently now. But I didn't think there was anything that was like embarrassing. No, you are so hard on yourself. This is an amazing, delightful episode. I know you and you're such an amazing writer. And I can see you watching things through the filter of like, oh, and and you're a producer and you direct. So I imagine you're watching it through all those different layers. Yeah, yeah, you know, there's everything. It's like framing. It's like, okay, should be a fun or that was repetitive. We already said that. Paul didn't need to do it again. But then I get really impressed with some other stuff.
然后还有，你知道的，我作为编剧的那部分就在想，哦，好吧，我想我现在会把那个处理得稍微不同一点。但我不觉得有什么让人觉得尴尬的地方。不，你对自己太严格了。这是一集精彩绝伦、令人愉悦的剧集。我了解你，你是一个如此出色的编剧。我能看出你在通过诸如“哦，而且”这样的滤镜观看，而且你还是制片人，你还执导。所以我想象你是在通过所有这些不同的层面来观看它。对，对，你知道，应有尽有。就像构图一样，比如，好吧，应该更有趣，或者那是重复的。我们已经说过了。保罗不需要再做一次。但随后我对其他一些事情留下了深刻的印象。
Well, we do always like to start by asking people how they came to be on the office. You are one of our original writers and you were with us the entire nine seasons. You were our showrunner as well for a period of time. How did it come about that you were on the show? Well, I had worked with Greg Daniels before and known him very long time. And we did King of the Hill together. And when they started the show, I, you know, I stopped by the pilot, you know, I had nothing to do with the pilot, but I stopped by a few days and it was, I just kind of loved what was happening. And it was, you know, I loved the British. And so then when it got picked up, I was, I was psyched that he asked me to come on. So there's just like kind
嗯，我们总是喜欢从询问大家是如何来到《办公室》的开始。你是我们的原班编剧之一，而且你陪伴我们度过了整整九季。有一段时间你还是我们的剧集运作人。你是怎么加入这部剧的？嗯，我以前和格雷格·丹尼尔斯合作过，认识他很长时间了。我们一起做过《山丘之王》。当他们开始做这个节目时，我，你知道的，我在试播集时顺便去过，你知道的，我跟试播集没什么关系，但我顺便去了几天，我只是有点喜欢正在发生的事情。而且，你知道的，我喜欢英国人。所以当它被预订时，我很兴奋，他邀请我加入。所以这里就像有一种
of a very traditional thing that writers and actors are kind of separating on a TV show, you know, and they're kind of asked not to talk. And he, at this point, was questioning a lot of those rules and why was this happening? And does this really make a better TV show? So we talked about roles for, it was Mindy and BJ and myself and Mike. And then there was a couple of consultants, there's Lester and Larry. So the four of us each got like little roles. I guess Mike's didn't come on most didn't start that season. But so we talked about just doing a little thing to kind of have the experience of being an actor. And hopefully it would inform our writing. So here he wanted to kind of like break that down together. So I feel like I'm not sure how Joey happened, but I feel
非常传统的事情，编剧和演员在电视节目中是某种程度上分开的，你知道的，他们某种程度上被要求不要说话。而他，在这一点上，对所有这些规则以及为什么会发生这种情况提出了质疑？这真的能让电视剧变得更好吗？所以我们讨论了角色，是明迪、B.J.和我自己还有迈克。然后还有几个顾问，有莱斯特和拉里。所以我们四个每个人都得到了一些小角色。我猜迈克的没有上，大部分人不是从那一季开始的。但所以我们讨论只是做一个小事情，为了有一种作为演员的体验。希望这能为我们的写作提供参考。所以在这里他想把那个打破，一起。所以我觉得我不太确定乔伊是怎么发生的，但我感觉
like I left the room and I came back and they said, you're gonna, you're gonna play this part. And it was one line, you know, in diversity day about, you know, I say this one line and get kicked out of the room. Now I heard Paul, and you tell me if this is true, I heard that at the table read, they had you read that line and that Steve as Michael jumped on you so viciously and everyone erupted in laughter because you sort of almost reacted a little bit as yourself and a little bit maybe how you thought Toby might, you know, but you still didn't know who Toby was at that moment, right? You're still discovering who is Toby. There were early table reads where it was just for like weird contractual reasons, just the main five actors. And I was, I was reading Kevin.
好像我离开了房间，然后我回来他们说，你要，你要扮演这个角色。只有一句台词，你知道的，在多元化日里，关于，你知道的，我说这句台词然后被踢出了房间。现在我听说，保罗，你告诉我这是否属实，我听说在剧本围读时，他们让你读那句台词，史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔像那样恶毒地扑向你，每个人都爆发出大笑，因为你几乎有点像本色反应，也有点像你认为托比可能会有的反应，你知道的，但你当时仍然不知道托比是谁，对吧？你还在发掘托比是谁。早期有几次剧本围读，仅仅是因为一些奇怪的合同原因，只有主要的五个演员。而我，我读的是凯文。
Yeah, you read a few roles. Yeah. And I think I did well. I think I got laughs this game. I think that the supporting cast wasn't there because you were guest stars and you were not series regulars. So in a series regular contract, you're required to do the table read. It's part of your acting deal, but I think they have to pay you more to attend those if you don't have that kind of contract. That sounds right. Yeah, you know, it's interesting because I, as a guest star, they, they say you're invited. Yeah. Right. Not required. You're invited if you would like to come. And I always do, but, but I think you're right. And it wasn't until after booze cruise that we started coming to table reads. Yeah. So Paul, you read a bunch of roles and, and everyone
对，你读了好几个角色。对。而且我觉得我表现得不错。我觉得我在这里得到了笑声。我觉得配角不在是因为你们是客串明星，而不是剧集常规演员。所以在一个剧集常规演员的合同中，你被要求参加剧本围读。这是你表演协议的一部分，但我认为如果你没有那种合同，他们必须付给你更多钱来参加这些活动。听起来是这样。是的，你知道的，有趣的是，作为客串明星，他们，他们说你是受邀的。是的。对吧。不是必须的。如果你想来，你是受邀的。我总是去，但是，但我认为你是对的，直到酒水巡游之后我们才开始来参加剧本围读。是的。所以保罗，你读了一堆角色，然后每个人
laughed when Michael jumped on you as Toby. And I feel like that helps seal the deal. But we also didn't expect that part to come back ever. Oh, that's how they got you. That's how, that's what Mike sure, that's what Mike sure said about Moe's. It's just so supposed to be a silly photo, you know? Yeah, yeah. He started as a photo. And then years later, he had to walk around with that beard for like a whole year, a whole season, because Greg wouldn't let him use a fake one. And it all started because he was just going to be in a photo. And then the fake one looked better, I think. Yes. And then he was furious because he had had that huge beard. And the fake one worked just as well. Well, Paul, how was that experience? Was Greg right? Did you feel like you learned from
当迈克尔作为托比扑向你时都笑了。我觉得这有助于达成交易。但我们也没想到那个角色会再回来。哦，这就是他们抓住你的方式。这就是，迈克·肖尔对莫斯说的就是这个。这本来应该只是一张傻气的照片，你知道的？对，对。他从一张照片开始。然后多年以后，他不得不顶着那个胡子走来走去，像整整一年，整整一季，因为格雷格不让他用假的。这一切的开始只是因为他要出现在一张照片里。然后我觉得假的看起来更好。是的。然后他气坏了，因为他留了那么大的胡子。而假的也同样管用。嗯，保罗，那次经历怎么样？格雷格是对的吗？你觉得你从
the experience of being an actor? I absolutely did. But it took a while to get there. I don't know if you remember, but we were doing this kind of room bit about like my acting school. I do remember your acting school bit. It's okay. So imagine going into acting knowing nothing about acting. And the first thing you're being taught is take your water bottle off your desk and put it underneath your desk. So because the label isn't cleared. All right, that's now the first thing I know about acting, you know, and it was like things like that that made up my acting school. Also, I remember Rain would just ride you so hard, like you go, Hey, Kate. And she goes, Hey, Paul. And you're like, Dang it. Because she was supposed to be married up in the moment
当演员的经历中学到了东西吗？我绝对学到了。但达到这一点花了点时间。我不知道你是否还记得，但我们在做一个关于我的表演学校的房间笑话。我记得你关于表演学校的笑话。没关系。所以想象一下，对表演一无所知地去演戏，你被教的第一件事就是把你的水瓶从桌子上拿下来，放在你的办公桌下面。因为商标没有被清理。好吧，这就是我关于表演知道的第一件事，你知道的，诸如此类的事情构成了我的表演学校。还有，我记得雷恩会把你逼得很紧，比如你走过去说，嘿，凯特。而她说，嘿，保罗。然后你就想，该死。因为她应该在场景中
you're in a scene. And I remember Rain would like tease you so hard. Yeah, there was very little acting I was doing. There was a breakthrough moment for me. They kept saying talk louder. And I wouldn't be like, No, you're I'm talking to a person right here. Why would I talk louder? You just ruled out multi cams for yourself. But that's okay. Yeah, and theater and theater. And then so we were doing a kitchen scene. And they kept telling me to speak up. And then Brian said, Why don't you imagine like this room is artificially quiet because they turned off the refrigerator, right? Because her sound. Why don't you imagine that the refrigerator is on and you have to talk. Oh, an actor does that. You know, it put this like, and it wasn't just like one
身处当下。我记得雷恩会这样狠狠地逗你。是的，我当时其实没做什么表演。对我来说有一个突破时刻。他们一直说大声点。而我不会，就像，不，你是，我正在和这儿的一个人说话。我为什么要大声说？你刚刚为自己排除了多机位情景喜剧。但没关系。是的，还有剧院和剧院。然后我们在拍一个厨房场景。他们一直告诉我要大声说出来。然后布莱恩说，你为什么不想象这个房间异常安静，因为他们关掉了冰箱，对吧？因为她的声音。你为什么不想象冰箱开着，你必须说话。哦，演员会那样做。你知道，它把这个像，而且不仅仅是一个
little thing. It was like, Oh, an actor has to put all these all those little details. It has to justify anything that needs to be done. They don't just do what feels real. They have to like find a way to do what they need to do and make it feel real. I love hearing that. Is this something that you've brought to other projects? Paul, as a writer, showrunner, creator of shows, have you asked your writing staff to act at all? I did. Let's see. I'm ghosted. I had Blitz's brother, Andy Blitz. And I'm created a part for him. Well, I have to say, and Jenna and I have talked about this a lot. And we talked about this one. Greg came on as well that we loved that we got to be around the writers. We loved when we got to go up into the writer's room. Sometimes we would
小事情。就像，哦，演员必须把所有那些小细节都加进去。它必须为需要做的事情找到合理的解释。他们不只是做感觉真实的事情。他们必须找到一种方法来做他们需要做的事情，并让它感觉真实。我很高兴听到这个。这是你带到其他项目中的东西吗？保罗，作为一个编剧、剧集运作人、节目的创作者，你有没有要求你的编剧团队去演戏？我有。让我想想。我被放鸽子了。我有布里ッツ的兄弟，安迪·布里ッツ。我为他创造了一个角色。嗯，我必须说，珍娜和我经常谈论这个。我们谈到这个时，格雷格也来了，我们很喜欢能和编剧们在一起。我们很喜欢去编剧室。有时我们会
shoot over in the warehouse and there was that back stairwell that went up where your kitchen was with your snacks. And we would come up and hang out. And it was really fun for us to have you guys on set. And it's hard for me to imagine other shows now without that creative collaboration and that feeling of safety and trust. And we've all worked on other shows where it is not the case. And it's something that I really cherish. Yeah, me too. Greg was right. It was it would breaking down that wall made us understand each other a lot better. And we all worked together. Well, speaking of having to team up for this episode, the job you teamed up with Mike, sure you guys co-wrote this episode. How did that work? I have kind of a memory of, you know,
在仓库那边拍摄，那里有通往楼上的后楼梯，通往放零食的厨房。我们会上来闲逛。对我们来说，有你们在片场真的很有趣。现在让我很难想象其他没有这种创意合作以及那种安全感和信任感的节目。我们都曾在其他节目中工作过，情况并非如此。这是我真正珍惜的东西。是的，我也是。格雷格是对的。打破这堵墙让我们彼此更加了解。我们大家一起工作。嗯，说到为这一集组队，“工作”这一集你和迈克·肖尔组队了，你们俩联合编剧了这一集。那是怎么运作的？我有一种记忆，你知道，
this was at the end of the season and a long season. And a lot of episodes are written in different ways. So it wasn't that Mike and I went off into a room together and then came out with the show. I think that we both were running the process of writing this episode together. You know, and we would we beat it all out with some writers would come in and out, but we would be the two people always there making sure, you know, the episode was what we wanted. And then he would go take a scene. I would take a scene or he would take a few writers to take a scene. And I would do the same. I think that's basically how this one worked. It's funny that you mention working in groups like that because I remember there were times on the set
这是在季末，一个漫长的赛季。许多剧集是以不同的方式编写的。所以并不是我和迈克一起走进一个房间然后拿出了这个节目。我认为我们两个是一起运行编写这一集的整个过程的。你知道的，我们会和一些进进出出的编剧一起把所有内容敲定，但我们俩会一直是确保这一集符合我们预期的人。然后他会拿一个场景。我会拿一个场景，或者他会带几个编剧去拿一个场景。我也会这样做。我想这基本上就是这一集运作的方式。有趣的是，你提到像这样在小组中工作，因为我记得片场有时
where Greg would call me off set. He would say, Jenna, are you in the scene? Are you in the scene? Okay, I've got three writers talking about Jim and Pam. I want you to sit in on that. Go in there. Go in there. Oh, my gosh, I would get so excited. I would be like, oh, I can't wait. I can't wait. And I mostly just listened. And sometimes I would throw out ideas. But that was so cool. Because you guys would kind of divide up a script and like a group of three people would go work on Dwight stuff. And then another three people would work on some other aspect of the story, at least from my little bit of experience in the writer's room. Well, it was it was episode by episode, you know, and some came in, some were really like
格雷格会把我叫出片场。他会说，珍娜，你在场景里吗？你在场景里吗？好吧，我有三个编剧在讨论吉姆和帕姆。我希望你旁听一下。进去。进去。哦，天哪，我会兴奋得要命。我会想，哦，我等不及了。我等不及了。我大部分时间只是听着。有时我会提出想法。但这太酷了。因为你们会把剧本分块，比如一个三人小组去处理德怀特的事情。然后另外三个小组去处理故事的其他方面，至少从我在编剧室的一点经验来看是这样的。嗯，这是一集一集来的，你知道，有些是编剧构思出来的，然后一路顺畅地完成了。有些是极具合作性的。但即使当一个编剧独自完成时，你知道的，对于将要发生什么也有大量的讨论。嗯，这一集的一个大故事情节是简和迈克尔复合了，而且简做了隆胸手术。我们对此故事情节非常好奇。比如，它是怎么诞生的？你和马拉拉谈过这件事吗？与马拉拉和史蒂夫合作是什么感觉？我想墙上挂着一张卡片很长时间了。我上面写着，简隆胸了。我们一直在寻找合适的地方。然后我们就必须分手。她隆胸了。正因为如此，他们又复合了。这是在鸡尾酒会上发生的事情。
conceived by the writer and went straight all the way through. And some were extremely collaborative. But even when a writer did it by himself or herself, there was, you know, there was tons of discussion about what was going to happen. Well, a big storyline in this episode is that Jan and Michael get back together and Jan has had breast augmentation. And we're so curious about this storyline. Like, how did it come about? Did you talk to Malora about it and working with Malora and Steve? What was that like? I think there was a card on the wall for a long time. I said, Jan gets a boot job. And we're kind of looking for the right place. And then so we had to break up. She gets a boot job. And because of that, they get back together. It was something
简在草坪上做了一段超级长的面对镜头独白，在……的草坪上，是的，在大卫·华莱士的房子前面。是的，在大卫·华莱士的房子前面。在写那段时，我们有点发现了简是如何走上自我毁灭之路的。是的。就像那为我们将其具象化了。就像，哦，她在毁掉自己。一旦我们明白了这一点，这就成了她堕落的一个阶段。嗯，太精彩了。我只是觉得马拉拉和史蒂夫再次展现了他们作为简和迈克尔的化学反应，对我来说，实在是太棒了。太棒了。我一整天都可以看他们。我最喜欢这一集的部分是她第一次走进来的时候，然后，他只是看着她，然后，珍娜，你就坐在那儿，
that happened during cocktails. Jan did this super long talking head on the lawn of the, the, yes, in front of David Wallace's house. Yeah, in front of David Wallace's house. And in writing that, we kind of discovered how Jan was on the road to self-destruction. Yes. It was like that crystallized it for us. It's like, oh, she's taking herself down. Once we got that, this was like a stage in her spiral. Well, it's so brilliant. I just thought Malora and Steve just once again, their dynamic as, as Jan and, and Michael to me, it's just so good. So good. I could watch them all day. My favorite part of the episode was when she came back in for the first time. And, uh, and he's just looking at her and, and Jenny, you're right there and
你向下看。是的。她说，为什么，为什么，私底下，为什么私底下？我喜欢我被直接放在他们俩中间。是的。这本可以是一个很普通、很平淡的小场景，你知道的，但他走在这条线上，既表现得刻薄，又试图保持礼貌、震惊、吓坏，同时又这一切都显得很真实。是的。看他这样做太有趣了。我不得不问你，谁对克里德的想法（Creed Thoughts）负责？你觉得那是迈克的面对镜头独白，然后杰森·凯斯勒把它写在了博客上。他在NBC.com上做了一个博客，
you're looking down. Yeah. And she's like, why, why, why privately, why privately? I loved how I was put right in the middle of the two of them. Yeah. It could have been just such a normal little dud of a scene, you know, but he walked this line of, of, of being like mean and, and trying to be polite and shocked and freaking out and making it all real at once. Yeah. It was so funny to see him do that. I have to ask you who is responsible for Creed Thoughts. You think that was a mic talking head and then Jason Kessler did it on the blog. He did a blog
也就是《克里德的想法》，我猜。他是你的编剧助理？是吗？对，对。然后他有点接管了数字媒体方面的东西。我这周为此给克里德发了短信。我说，克里德，你还记得《克里德的想法》，你的整个博客吗？他说，对，对，那挺有趣的。我没写过那些。但那个博客持续了一年，是杰森以克里德的名义写的。对，对。好吧。所以这一集引入了“施鲁特币（Schrute Bucks）”，这太滑稽了。谁想出来的？而且我留了一个。我有一个施鲁特币。你有？对。裱起来了吗？没有。我想我应该把它裱起来。它可能，
of Creed Thoughts on NBC.com, I guess. And he was your writer's assistant. Is that right? Yeah. Yeah. And then he kind of took over the digital media stuff. I texted Creed about it this week. I was like, Creed, do you remember Creed Thoughts, your whole blog? He was like, yeah, yeah, that was fun. I didn't write any of that. But that went on for a year, that blog that Jason wrote as Creed. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So this episode introduces the shrewt bucks, which are hilarious. And who came up with that? And also I saved one. I have a shrewt buck. You do? Yeah. Does it frame? No. I guess I should frame it. It's probably,
就像在一个我还没整理到的剪贴簿箱子里。好吧，那也行。是个大的还是小的，安吉拉？是个大的。好的。我不知道你们是否还记得，我想这是一个被剪掉的场景，但是克里德试图冲击美元的价值，试图冲击市场。所以他有一个被剪掉的场景，他在疯狂地复印，四处张望，确保没有人看到他。然后他推着一整车数千个施鲁特币，来到了德怀特，就像德怀特的新办公室，他说，除非你付钱，否则我要用这些宝贝冲击市场。所以我的记忆是，片场到处都是。我们有一堆堆的。
it's like in a scrapbook bin that I haven't gotten to. Well, that'll do it. Is it a large one or a small one, Angela? It's the large one. Okay. And I don't know if you guys remember, and I think it's a deleted scene, but Creed tries to flood the value of the dollar, try to flood the market. So he has this deleted scene where he's photocopying like crazy and he's looking around, make sure no one's seeing him. And then he wheels in to Dwight, like Dwight's new office, this whole cart full of thousands of shrewt bucks. And he's like, I'm going to flood the market with these babies unless you pay up. So my memory is they were everywhere on set. We had stacks of them.
我把那个场景忘了。是的。它没有保留下来，但真的很好笑。是的，那很有趣。我认为贾斯汀·斯皮策想出了施鲁特币。哦，他太有趣了。不是百分之百确定。是的。他太棒了。他喜欢，他喜欢德怀特。这些年来，很多关于德怀特的东西都源于他。嗯，贾斯汀做了双胞胎吸收。我们发现了。是的。是的。是的。这让我想起了一个有趣的事情，保罗，我记得这些年来会有不同的编剧真的很喜欢某个特定的角色。比如迈克·肖尔喜欢看安吉拉·马丁崩溃。我总是能看出什么时候是他的剧本，
I forgot about that scene. Yeah. It's not, it didn't make it, but it's really funny. Yeah. That is funny. I think that Justin Spitzer thought of shrewt bucks. Oh, he's so funny. Not a hundred percent. Yeah. He's great. And he loved, he loved to Dwight. There was a lot of Dwight stuff over the years that came out of him. Well, Justin did twin absorption. We found out. Yes. Yes. Yeah. That brings up an interesting thing to me, Paul, is that I remember over the years there'd be different writers that would just really love a specific character. Like Mike sure loved to see Angela Martin fall apart. I could always tell when it was one of his scripts,
我的角色就会失控。你有没有一个你喜欢为其写剧本的角色？我想我都喜欢写所有人。但克里德总是很有趣。凯文总是很好玩，只要把他推向极限。是的。所以最终写了一集他甚至不知道字母表的。我记得和他一起做到那一步，当他做这件事时，我笑得前仰后合。迈克尔，我有时仍然像在开车时会想到迈克尔的一段面对镜头独白。我想写，你知道的，他的声音在我的脑海里是如此清晰。它是如此独特。是的。你知道，我怀念那个为他写剧本的角色。
my character would spiral out. Did you have a character that you love to write for? I love doing everybody, I think. But Creed was always fun. Kevin was always like fun to just push to the limits. Yeah. So eventually doing one where he didn't know the alphabet. I remember going that far with him and just I was laughing so hard during all he was doing it. Michael, I still sometimes like I'm driving and I think of like a Michael talking head. I want to write, you know, is it's his voice is just so clear in my head. It's so distinct. Yeah. You know, I miss that character that's right for him.
嗯，保罗，你有什么最喜欢的场景或来自这一集的时刻吗？或者有什么你想分享的最喜欢的时刻？甚至不必来自这一集。但如果有的话。当亨特在做时，我真的哈哈大笑，他对亨特说，告诉她我想捏捏它们。是的。她会懂我的意思。这很好。是的。现在我在剧本里查了，第二部分不在剧本里。我有这种感觉。哦，太好了。我很高兴你查了，因为我，我在想。我敢打赌他把第一部分“告诉她我想捏捏它们。她会懂我的意思”写进去了。是的。然后我喜欢简发现自己被解雇了，她冲进华莱士的房间。
Well, Paul, do you have like a favorite scene or moment from this episode or anything you want to share like a favorite moment? It doesn't even have to be from this episode. But if there was one. I really laughed out loud when Hunter and he was telling Hunter to tell her I want to squeeze them. Yeah. She'll know what I mean. It's good. Yeah. Now I looked in the script and the second part was not in the script. I had a feeling. Oh, good. I'm glad you checked it out because I was I was wondering. I bet he but the first one was the teller I want to squeeze them. She'll know what it means was in there. Yes. And then I loved when Jane finds out she's fired and she storms into Wallace's
他们进行了一场激烈的争吵，他把她痛骂了一顿。我喜欢大卫表现得多么坚定。就像他非常冷静，感觉，是的，这是一个非常坚实的具有代表性的角色，因为在这个节目中，有太多人只是害怕或羞于说出真相。好吧。然后当她离开后有这样一个时刻，迈克尔站在门框后面说，我没告诉她。就像，不是我。他甚至不敢看，而且，夸帕斯的构图方式是，他就像门框正好卡在空间的中间。我喜欢，当，
room. They have this kind of screaming match and he tells her off. And I loved how strong David was. Like he was just so collected and felt like, yeah, just really solid character to have because so many people are just kind of scared or inhibited to say the truth on that show. Okay. So then there's this moment after she leaves where Michael's standing behind the dorm frame and says, I didn't tell her. I was like, it wasn't me. And he can't even look and he's, he's, the way Qwatha's framed it was, he was kind of like the door frame was right coming down in the middle of the space. I loved, I loved when,
你知道的，简正在向大卫·华莱士发飙，而迈克尔就在你说的那个位置。有一刻他说，对。然后大卫·华莱士说，不好意思，就像只是用一个眼神。迈克尔就说，不，不。好的。好的。嗯，我们收到了粉丝的一个问题，保罗。我必须问，这是来自萨拉·麦金蒂和朱一旺的提问。他们想知道，为什么卡伦没有得到总公司的职位？因为你设定了该职位的一个要求是四年销售经验。但瑞恩，我们认为他在那里工作没有四年，而且他从来没有做过销售。为什么大卫·华莱士会选择他？他们想知道，你这样做是不是为了让B.J.离开片场去编剧室，这样他就可以做他的编剧工作了？
you know, Jan is just like letting David Wallace have it and Michael is in that same spot you're talking about. And for one moment he's like, yeah. And then David Wallace is like, excuse me, like just with a look. And Michael's like, nope, nope. Okay. Okay. Well, we got one question from a fan, Paul. And I have to ask, this is from Sarah McGinty and Zhu Yi Wang. They want to know, why didn't Karen get the job at corporate? Because you set up that one of the requirements for the job was sales experience of four years. But Ryan, we don't think has worked there for four years and he's never made a sale. Why did David Wallace choose him? They want to know, did you do this so that you could get BJ off the set and into the writer's room so he could do his writing job?
不，可能恰恰相反。我觉得，我们认为让瑞恩当一段时间迈克尔的老板会带来很多有趣的喜剧效果。他是那个进来的临时工。他显然是个非常擅长胡扯的人，但却很不称职。我想这就是我们这么做的原因。我想我们说他在管理学校上了一小会儿。他拿到了MBA，对吧？那是其中之一。我不确定他是怎么在半夜做到这一点的。但我的意思是，在现实世界中的原因，可能是他真的用MBA深深震撼了大卫，并说对了所有正确的话。所以我能看到，我能看到它发生。但真正的原因是，你知道的，是时候让卡伦离开这个剧了。而且，你知道的，我们在第四季中对吉姆和帕姆的处理。
No, probably opposite. It was, I think we thought we would get a lot of fun comedy out of putting Ryan as Michael's boss for a while. He was the temp that came in. He's clearly a really good bullshitter, but it's, but incompetent. And I think that's how we got it. I think we say he went to management school for a little. He got an MBA, right? That was one of the things. I'm not sure how he did that in midnight. But I mean, the reasoning in the real world, I could have been, he just really kind of dazzled David with the MBA and said all the right things. So I could see, I could see it happening. But the real reason was like, you know, it was, it was time for Karen to leave the show. And, you know, what we were doing with Jim and Pam for season four.
然后，然后我们觉得这将是一个有趣的动态转变。我想这就是我们一直在寻找这些配对的时候，你知道的，把人们换一下，谁有一段时间没有在一起了，你知道的，所以我们把你俩的照片都放上去。我想知道关于你和你，我们拍过场景吗？如果你是他的老板会怎么样，你知道的，你总是像，悲伤的，你知道的，即兴表演中的地位游戏或权力动态，你知道的，只是把他们换一下。我太喜欢了。我真的太喜欢了。我真的能理解为什么总公司里的瑞恩会只是，这几乎是莎士比亚式的，你知道的，就像迈克尔认为自己是国王，而这个卑微的，像个农民一样的人直接从他身边走过了，
And then, and then we thought it would be just a fun dynamic switch. I think it's when we were always looking for these pairings, you know, switch people up, who hasn't been together in a while, you know, so we have all your pictures up. I wonder about you and you, have we done a scene? What if you were his boss, you know, and you're always like, sad, you know, status games and improv or power dynamics, you know, just switching them up. I loved it. I just loved it so much. I could really see why Ryan at corporate would just be, it's almost Shakespearean, you know, it's like Michael thinks of himself as the king and this like lowly, like peasant just, just went right past him,
你知道的，在食物链上。我喜欢他说，给我一杯咖啡，你知道的。然后，然后现在，现在瑞恩直接越过他，将要去总公司了。而且他跟凯莉说再见的方式，他就像是，冷酷的，他是冷酷无情的。但你能看出那里会有些乐趣。是的。是的。他就像，我们完了。是的。保罗，当你回首过去并对自己说，我希望我们拍了这一场景时，有什么事吗，因为我记得编剧室的墙上挂着一张卡片，挂了好多年好多年，从来没有被拍出来过。它一直萦绕在我的脑海里。上面写着双人约会。这将是吉姆和帕姆与德怀特和安吉拉的双人约会。我一直希望我们能看到那个双人约会。我甚至记得在
you know, on the food chain. And I love that he was like, give me a coffee, you know. And then, and then now, now Ryan just jumped right over him and it's going to be at corporate. And just the way he says goodbye to Kelly, he's like, cold, he's cold hearted. But you can see that there's going to be some fun there. Yeah. Yeah. He's like, we're done. Yeah. Paul, is there anything when you look back and you think to yourself, I wish we had done this scene, because I remember there was a card on the writer's room wall for years and years and years that never got made. And it haunts me. And it said double date. And it was going to be a double date with Jim and Pam and Dwight and Angela. And I always wish we had seen that double date. And I even remember being
编剧室里听到你们试图证明为什么吉姆和帕姆会同意和德怀特和安吉拉去双人约会。我们怎么反过来？安吉拉为什么会出席？我想“晚宴派对”有点像那样，对吧？我们在那里确实进行了一种双重三重约会，四重约会，真的，因为德怀特带了他的保姆。有什么你记得的卡片你不得不留在墙上吗？你不得不把它们留在身后？我绝对确信有。双人约会会很有趣。有时是找到那个杀手级笑话。也许我们本应该只是一直在推销历史上将要发生的事情。我们找到了那个，无论付出什么代价我们都会去证明它。保罗，非常感谢你来。
in the writer's room and hearing you guys try to justify why Jim and Pam would agree to go on a double date with Dwight and Angela. How could our vice versa? Why would Angela ever attend? And I think dinner party was sort of that, right? We all did go out on our kind of double triple date there, quadruple date, really, with since Dwight brought his babysitter. Were there any cards that you remember that you had to leave on the wall? You had to leave them behind? I'm absolutely sure there were. Double date would have been fun. Sometimes it's finding the killer joke. Maybe we should have just been pitching on what is the historical thing that's going to happen. We find that, we'll do whatever it takes to justify it. Paul, thank you so much for coming
显然，大家能请到你非常激动。谢谢邀请我。嗯，谢谢保罗。很高兴见到你。希望我们能很快再次聚聚。我也希望如此。好的，保罗。保罗，保重。再见，保罗。再见。嗯，那真是太有趣了。我喜欢我们邀请编剧上节目。而保罗既是编剧又是演员。他带来了如此酷的视角，对吧，珍娜？是的。嗯，听着，我们想在这里向保罗致敬。他有一个非常有趣的全新项目，将于2021年春季推出。它将在Audible上播出，是一个名为《船长（Captain）》的节目。他说这就像一个老式广播节目，是一部科幻片，但它是反科幻片。我喜欢这个描述。它是反科幻片的。珍娜就像是，
on. Obviously, these are just thrilled to have you. Thanks for having me on. Yeah. Well, thanks, Paul. It was really good to see you. And I hope that we can have another get together really soon. I hope so, too. All right, Paul. Take care, guys. Bye, Paul. Bye. Well, that was just too much fun. I love it when we have writers on the show. And Paul is the writer actor. He brings such a cool perspective, right, Jenna? Yeah. Well, listen, we want to give Paul a shout out here. He has a really funny new project coming out spring of 2021. It's going to be on Audible, and it's a show called Captain. He said it's like an old time radio show, and it's a sci-fi, but it's anti-sci-fi. I love this description. It's anti-sci-fi. Jenna's like,
我加入了。它有威尔·福特、约翰·马尔科维奇、雷恩·威尔逊、亚当·斯科特、怀亚特·塞纳克、吉莉安·雅各布斯，很多有趣的人。请留意2021年春季。Audible上的《船长》。是的。他说这就像他们都在太空中，但没有任何科幻的事情发生在他们身上，我只是觉得太有趣了。我等不及了。我等不及了。嗯，听着，伙计们，我们要休息一下，然后当我们回来时，我们将开始剖析“工作”这一集。好的。所以这一集以迈克尔在总公司进行面试开场，面试是明天。是的。他弄错日子了，现在他得掩盖自己的屁股。是的。他在试图拯救它，但他做得糟糕透顶。是的。我想指出一件事。当他和大卫·华莱士
I'm on board. It has Will Forte, John Malkovich, Rayne Wilson, Adam Scott, Wyatt Senak, Gilly and Jacobs, lots of funny folks. Be looking for it spring 2021. Captain on Audible. Yeah. He said it's like they're all out in space, but there's nothing sci-fi happening to them, which I just thought was so funny. I can't wait. I can't wait. Well, listen, guys, we will take a break, and then when we come back, we will start breaking down the job. All right. So this episode opens with Michael at corporate for his interview, which is tomorrow. Yeah. He got the day wrong, and now he's got to cover his butt. Yeah. He's trying to save it, and he does a horrible job. Yeah. And I wanted to point out something. While him and David Wallace
在谈话时，我看了一下前台。总公司前台没有植物。哦，天哪。现在你在追踪总公司前台的植物了。我怎么了？但在33秒时，有一个非常好的特写镜头，拍到了后面的一些干枯的棕色树枝。就像树枝，大大的、看起来很高的树枝。我的意思是，它们不是真的活的，对吧？这是某种装饰。嗯，显然，总公司的前台做得对。她不必让任何植物保持活着。她只有一个装满树枝的罐子。我喜欢。帕姆可以学到点东西。我们该进入正题了。所以吉姆到达公司上班，珍娜，吉姆换了个新发型。确实换了。梅雷迪思觉得看起来很性感。哦，是的。而凯文觉得他看起来还可以更糟。安迪
are talking, I looked at reception. No plants at reception corporate. Oh my gosh. Now you're tracking the plants at corporate reception. What's wrong with me? But at 33 seconds, there is a really good shot of some dried brown sticks in the back. It's like sticks, big, tall looking sticks. I mean, they're not really alive, right? This is some kind of decor. Well, clearly, the receptionist at corporate is doing something right. She doesn't have to keep any plants alive. She's just got a jar with sticks. I like it. Pam could learn something. We should get into the episode. So Jim arrives to work, and Jenna, Jim has a new haircut. He does. Meredith thinks it looks sexy. Oh, yeah. And Kevin thinks he could look worse. Andy
立刻说，你不再是大金枪鱼了，你是大发型。嗯，我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝问候，安吉拉。萨曼莎·帕蒂诺、凯拉·奥、凯蒂·诺尔德、杰斯·康、娜塔莉·佩恩以及许多其他人写信来问，吉姆的发型是编剧的选择吗？还是他换发型有其他原因？两者兼有。两者兼有。两者兼有。它在剧本里，但它必须在剧本里，因为约翰理发了。嗯，约翰当时正在和乔治·克鲁尼以及勒妮·齐薇格拍一部名为《皮头盔（Leatherheads）》的电影。就像，它设定在不同的时代，所以他留了短发。但这非常适合这个故事，因为我觉得很好，卡伦说，你需要理发，你要去总公司面试。而且吉姆确实
immediately says, you're no longer big tuna, you're big haircut. Well, we got a lot of fan questions about this, Angela. Samantha Patino, Kayla Oh, Katie Nolder, Jess Conn, Natalie Payne, and many others wrote in to ask, was Jim's haircut a writer choice? Or was there another reason he got the haircut? It was both. It was both. It was both. It was in the script, but it had to be in the script because John got a haircut. Well, John was doing a movie with George Clooney and Reneza Wigger called Leather Heads. And it was like, it was set in a different time, and so he had shorter hair. But it worked out perfect for the story because I think it's great that Karen's like, you need a haircut, you're going to interview for corporate. And Jim did
有点那种蓬乱的头发，你知道吗？所以我喜欢作为女朋友的卡伦说，你得把它收拾干净。但这季有几集，你们中的一些人问过，随着约翰在电影中的那个发型慢慢长回来，约翰确实戴了假发。是的。而我们没有谈过这个，这对我来说太疯狂了。但是，是的，在他为电影剪了超短发后回到了办公室，为了头发长出来，他不得不戴了一段时间的假发。然后最后对于这一集，我想他们觉得头发已经长得足够长了，看起来更像是现代的发型。所以他们，约翰是，这是约翰真正的头发，伙计们。是的，是的。你们，我去了《皮头盔》
kind of have this shaggy hair, you know? So I liked that Karen as the girlfriend was like, you got to clean it up. But there were a few episodes this season, some of you guys have asked that, that as, as John's hair was sort of transitioning back from that haircut of the movie that he did wear a wig. Yes. And we have not talked about that, which is so crazy to me. But yeah, after he got the super short haircut for the movie, he came back to the office and he had to wear a wig for a while whereas hair grew out. And then finally for this episode, I think they felt like it had grown out enough that it looked like a more modern day haircut. So they, John is, this is John's real hair, folks. Yes, yes. You guys, I went to the Leather Heads
首映礼，我遇到了约翰的家人。我简直不敢相信。我走到他们那群人中间。约翰说，嘿，伙计们，这是我的朋友安吉拉。然后他们转过身来。他们是最高的人。约翰是他兄弟中个子最矮的。他身高六英尺三英寸。他身高六英尺三英寸。他是最矮的。我就想，哦，天哪，就像，就像我们来自两个不同的星球。但他们太可爱了。能够去那样支持他真的很有趣。是的。是的，当他在拍那部电影时真的很酷。实际上，当我们得到这些工作时，我们会为彼此感到兴奋。我们会说，把一切都告诉我们。我知道。我就想，乔治·克鲁尼，拜托。不，不过我想指出他面对镜头独白时的一点，
premiere and I met John's family. And I could not believe it. I walked up to the group of them. And John was like, Hey guys, this is my friend Angela. And they turned around. And they were the tallest people. John is the shortest of his brother's guys. And he's like six three. He's six three. He's the shortest. I was like, Oh my gosh, it was like, it was like we're from two different planets. But they were so lovely. And that was so fun to be able to go support him like that. Yeah. Yeah, that was really cool when he was shooting that movie. Actually, we would get excited for each other when we would get these jobs. And we'd be like, tell us all about it. I know. I was like, George Clooney, come on. No, I wanted to point out something though with his talking
你知道，他说卡伦建议他为面试理发，珍娜，这是一个重大的女朋友时刻。我的意思是，a，这表明吉姆真的在听卡伦说话。你知道的，你在改变自己的外表，特别是当你多年来一直留着相同的发型或外表时。这是一件大事。所以他采纳了她的建议。我想，哦，哇，他们的关系真的很稳固。就像我当时深信不疑。我在想，哇，吉姆完全投入了。然后我想这也表明他是真的想要得到这份工作。嗯，这一集里，会有成吨的悬念。我们根本没有透露这一切的结局会是什么。从海滩游戏回来后，就像，帕姆在海滩上的表白会带来什么后果。
head. You know, he says that Karen suggested that he get a haircut for his interview. And Jenna, this is a major girlfriend moment. I mean, a it shows that Jim is actually really listening to Karen. You know, you're changing your look, especially when you've had the same haircut or same look for years and years. That's a big deal. And so he took her advice. And I thought, Oh, wow, their relationship's really solid. Like I was believing it. I'm like, wow, Jim's all in. And then I thought it also shows that he he really wants to get the job. Well, in this episode, there are going to be a ton of Mr. X. We do not show our hand for what the end of this is going to be at all. And coming back from beach games, it was like, what is going to
所以以吉姆和卡伦比以往任何时候都更恩爱来开场这一集，帕姆就像是，听着，进展得很顺利。没关系。她有那整段面对镜头独白，她说，我知道我花了三年时间才鼓起勇气把我的感受告诉吉姆。但是，你知道，我很高兴我这么做了。现在结束了。我们都向前看了。这就是我们这一集的开场。我们都向前看了。吉姆理了发。他喜欢女朋友的建议。我真的，呃，我甚至不知道该用什么词，也许是对帕姆的面对镜头独白感到敬畏，关于她是如何表现得像，我毫无遗憾。这件事必须说出来。我说了，因为我会吓坏的。我会觉得太尴尬了，因为我在
be the repercussion of Pam's confession on the beach. And so to open this episode with Jim and Karen stronger than ever, Pam is like, listen, it went great. It was fine. She has that whole talking head where she's like, I know it only took me three years to summon the courage to tell Jim my feelings. But, you know, I'm glad I did it. And now it's over. We're all moving on. That's how we open this episode. We're all moving on. Jim has a haircut. He likes his girlfriend's advice. I was really, um, I don't even know the word like in awe, maybe of Pam's talking head about how she was like, I have no regrets. It needed to be said. And I said it because I would have been horrified. I would have been so embarrassed like that I have this huge like emotional speech in
所有同事面前做了一场如此巨大的充满情感的演讲。但接着你第二天就得在明亮的荧光灯下出现在工作岗位上。是的。嗯，他们确实稍微逗了逗她。有很多被删减的场景。有一个主线剧情，我们稍后会看到一个。但你确实被大家稍微取笑了，不过是充满爱意的取笑。是的。好吧，接下来，迈克尔在他的办公室里。他把德怀特叫进来，并解释说，是时候我来指定我的接班人了。他递给德怀特一个信封。是的。里面是迈克尔写的一张便条，上面写着德怀特，恭喜，威皮，别搞砸了。这带来了，这让德怀特泣不成声。这让德怀特泣不成声。啜泣流泪。我听了DVD评论音轨，他们在评论音轨里说雷恩饰演的德怀特
front of all of my coworkers. But then you got to show up to work the next day with everyone in the bright fluorescent light. Yeah. Well, they do tease her a little bit. They're a bunch of deleted scenes. There's a runner and we'll see one later. But you do get made fun of a little bit, but lovingly by everyone. Yes. Well, next up, Michael is in his office. He calls Dwight in and he explains, it's time for me to name my successor. He hands Dwight an envelope. Yes. And inside there is a written note from Michael that says Dwight, congratulations, a wipe, don't screw the pooch. This brings, this brings Dwight's sobbing. It brings Dwight's sobbing. Sobbing tears. I listened to the DVD commentary and they said in the commentary that rain as Dwight
在所有同事面前。但第二天你还得去上班，在明亮的荧光灯下面对所有人。是的。嗯，他们确实拿她开了一点玩笑。这有很多删减片段。有一个贯穿情节，我们稍后会看到一个。不过你确实会被大家取笑一点，但大家都很有爱意。是的。好的，接下来，迈克尔在他的办公室里。他把德怀特叫进来并解释说，是时候让我指定我的继承人了。他递给德怀特一个信封。是的。里面有一张迈克尔写的便条，上面写着“德怀特，恭喜，一个湿巾，别搞砸了”。这让，这让德怀特泣不成声。这让德怀特泣不成声。泣不成声。我听了DVD的评论音轨，他们在评论里说雷恩饰演的德怀特
went on and on so long sobbing, they just let him just sob, Ken Quoth has just let him go and let him go. And Ken said it went on for so long. And Steve started saying, you know what? Just forget it. Give me the letter back. I take it back. Well, we had a fan catch in the scene, which is really delightful, Angela. Christina Juarez and John Sperry wrote in to say in Michael's office, when he hands Dwight the letter, you can see an outlet on the wall behind Michael and it is upside down. What is going on here? Oh my God, Angela, it is. It is right around three minutes, 11 seconds by the coat rack behind Michael. It's an upside down electrical outlet, like the little hole part is on the top and then the two lines are underneath it. I know, I know what an upside
一直在那抽泣，他们就由着他哭，肯·夸帕斯就由着他哭个没完。肯说这哭了太久了。然后史蒂夫开始说，你知道吗？算了吧。把信还给我。我收回。好了，这集里有个粉丝发现的细节，真的很有趣，安吉拉。克里斯蒂娜·华雷斯和约翰·斯佩里写信说，在迈克尔的办公室里，当他把信递给德怀特时，你能看到迈克尔身后的墙上有一个插座，而且它是倒装的。这到底是怎么回事？哦，天哪，安吉拉，还真是。就在大约3分11秒处，迈克尔身后的衣帽架旁边。那是一个倒装的电源插座，小孔部分在上面，然后两个插孔在下面。我知道，我知道倒装
down outlet would look like. But thank you for, thank you for like walking us through it. Well, if you want to see one go to three minutes and 11 seconds. Well, that's a great catch. You guys know I will go back and look for it. Here's something, Angela. Of course, we know that that outlet didn't really work. It was just, you know, a fake outlet cover, but it did get me wondering. So I went to the website, familyhandyman.com. Oh, Lord. And it says that there is actually no right way to install an outlet. You can install it, quote, upside down. You can install it sideways. It will not affect how the outlet works. It actually said, quote, it's up to you. There's no standard electrical outlet orientation. So there's really no such thing as an upside down
的插座是什么样的。但谢谢你，谢谢你带我们回顾这个细节。如果你想看一看，就调到3分11秒。嗯，真是个好发现。你们知道我会倒回去找它的。安吉拉，还有个事。当然，我们知道那个插座其实并不通电。它只是个，你知道的，假插座盖，但这确实让我好奇。所以我上了familyhandyman.com这个网站。哦，天哪。上面说，其实安装插座并没有所谓的正确方向。你可以“倒装”安装它。你可以横着安装它。这完全不会影响插座的使用。它甚至说，引述一下，“随你便，标准电源插座没有方向要求。”所以根本没有所谓的倒装插
outlet. Well, that makes sense. It does make sense. I found it interesting. I feel like my, I definitely need to tell my dad about familyhandyman.com. Oh, your dad will love it. I also want to say before we move on that I noticed that there are also two light switches in the middle of Michael's wall underneath a giant framed picture. Now that is odd. Why would you put your light switches there? I guess it's because when you walk in the door, he has like glass. So you can't, but he has to walk real far into his office to turn on the lights. Well, you know what? He never has to do it because Dwight gets there early and sets up his office for him. Yeah. Michael doesn't even know where those lights switches are. He's never had to turn them on. Well, they're right
座。嗯，倒也合理。确实挺合理的。我觉得挺有意思。我觉得我，我绝对得把我爸推荐给familyhandyman.com这个网站。哦，你爸一定会喜欢的。在继续之前我还想说，我注意到迈克尔墙中间、一个巨大的有框画下面还有两个电灯开关。这就很奇怪了。你为什么要把电灯开关安在那儿？我想是因为当你走进门时，他装的是那种玻璃。所以你不能，但他必须走到办公室很深处才能开灯。好吧，你知道吗？他根本不用自己动手，因为德怀特去得很早，会帮他布置好办公室。对。迈克尔甚至不知道那些电灯开关在哪儿。他从来没开过。嗯，它们就在
there under the picture. You know what, Angela, you spot plants. I'm going to be on the lookout for outlets. Well, between the two of us, look out world. That's right. Well, next up. Oh, the scene between Pam and Karen. Oh my gosh. I thought Rashida did such an amazing job because she had to react to so many things as Karen. First of all, she's graciously, I think, trying to let Pam off the hook. She's like, you know what? It happens. Sometimes we just have those moments. We say things we don't mean. And then Pam is like, oh no, I meant it. I've thought about it a long time. And Karen, the look that comes over her face, she's like, oh, that's how it is. Yeah. And then she has her talking head where she's like, Pam is kind of a bitch. Yeah.
画底下。你知道吗，安吉拉，你专门找这种细节。那我要开始留心找找插座了。嗯，咱们俩加起来，世界可要小心了。没错。好了，接下来。哦，帕姆和凯伦之间的戏。哦，天哪。我觉得雷史黛拉表现得太棒了，因为她作为凯伦必须对很多事情作出反应。首先，我觉得她表现得很有风度，试图给帕姆一个台阶下。她就像是，你知道吗？这种事难免发生。有时我们就是会情绪上头。说出一些言不由衷的话。然后帕姆却说，哦不，我是认真的。我考虑很久了。而凯伦，她脸上露出的表情仿佛在说，哦，原来是这样。对。然后她有段单独访谈，大概意思是帕姆简直是个碧池。对。
Yeah. I would be ticked off. I would not be happy with Pam. Pam. Well, here was my thing as the character of Pam, because in watching it as an audience member, it was rude. Like Pam is not being great in that scene. But not being great in that scene. She's also flirting with Jim in front of Karen. It's like, all bets are off with Pam now. She walked across these coals. She's feeling empowered. And when did she flirt with Jim in front of Karen? Hi. I like your haircut. I like it. Smile. Come on. Come on. Right out of the gate. And then later, when he's leaving for corporate, she's like, good luck. Oh my gosh, you have such strong feelings. I didn't know. I feel like Pam is openly flirting
对。我要是她也会被惹毛的。我对帕姆可不会有好脸色。帕姆。好吧，作为帕姆这个角色，我是这么看的，因为以观众的视角来看，这确实很粗鲁。就好像帕姆在那场戏里表现得不怎么好。但不仅在那场戏里表现不好。她还在凯伦面前跟吉姆调情。这就好比，帕姆现在彻底放飞自我了。她火中取栗过了。她现在信心满满。什么时候在凯伦面前跟吉姆调情了？嗨。我喜欢你的发型。我很喜欢。笑一个。来吧。来吧。一开场就是这样。然后后来，当他准备去总公司时，她还说，祝你好运。哦天哪，你情绪这么激烈。我之前都不知道。我觉得帕姆在这集里就是在凯伦面前
with Jim in front of Karen in this episode. Okay. My backstory as Pam, it's one of those things where when you finally get your voice, you just say everything. You lose all of your editing for a period of time, right? Because you have to try on this new way of being, and you're going to mess it up sometimes. The pendulum has swung in the other direction, and Pam is really living in, oh, I'm sorry, I hold nothing back now. I give zero Fs. I say it all. And you all are going to have to live with it. That's the world Pam is in right now. Yes. She has an auto corrected to sort of like a happy medium. She's just swung real hard one way. She has. Well, then Karen suggests to Jim that they leave for New York tonight and they should
明目张胆地和吉姆调情。好吧。作为帕姆的背景故事，这其实是那种当你终于敢于表达自我时，就会把心里话全盘托出的情况。在一段时间里，你完全失去了自我审查的能力，对吧？因为你不得不尝试这种崭新的生活方式，而且有时你难免会搞砸。天平已经向另一个方向倾斜了，帕姆现在真的很享受这种状态，哦，不好意思，我现在什么都不憋着了。我一点都不在乎了。我什么都敢说。你们所有人都得接受这一点。这就是帕姆现在的世界。没错。她没有自动纠正到一个比较适中的状态。她只是用力过猛了。确实如此。好吧，接着凯伦向吉姆提议今晚一起去纽约，他们应该
get a hotel room and hang out in the city. Oh yeah. Karen is like, let's get out of here. Because that bitch behind reception is coming from a man and we need to go. Well, Angie, we actually had a fan catch from this scene. Anna Owen and Ishan Vasant both wrote in to say at four minutes 43 seconds when Karen suggests leaving early, Jim says he has too much paperwork to do and then he signs a document in pencil. Who does that? Did you notice he signs his name in pencil? I did a good catch. I did not notice. I did not notice, but I sort of just feel like none of them do any real work all day. Hannah Settle also has a fan catch for this scene. And it involves you. Oh, what am I doing? At four minutes 33 seconds, Angela and Kevin are talking
找个酒店房间在城里逛逛。哦对。凯伦的意思是，咱们离开这儿吧。因为前台后面那个碧池对一个男人虎视眈眈，我们得赶紧走。哦，安吉拉，其实这场戏里也有粉丝发现了一个穿帮。安娜·欧仁和伊尚·瓦桑都写信说，在4分43秒时，当凯伦提议早点离开，吉姆说他还有很多文件要处理，然后他竟然用铅笔在一份文件上签名。谁会这么做？你注意到了吗？他用铅笔签名耶。我注意到了，这发现得真好。我之前没注意到。我没注意到，不过我其实觉得他们整天根本都不干正经工作。汉娜·塞特尔对这场戏也有个粉丝发现。而且跟你有关。哦，我怎么了？在4分33秒时，安吉拉和凯文在背景里聊天
together in the background. And she wants to know what are some of the things you guys would talk about during scenes when you were in the deep background? Because I watched this scene twice. One, so that I could watch Jim sign in pencil. And then two, so that I could watch you and Brian in the background and lady. I know. It's you and Brian just chatting back there. No, I know, I know. I actually, I actually chuckled to myself when I saw this scene because, you know, they had a standing there. So we would be in the shot. They would often do that. They would put Brian and I at a file cabinet and Oscar could stay at his desk because he was in the line of sight, but they would have to pull Brian out and me out. So we would stand at those fog cabinets back there.
。她想知道，当你们在很深的背景里拍戏时，通常会聊些什么？因为我看这场戏看了两遍。第一遍是为了看吉姆用铅笔签名。第二遍是为了看你和布莱恩在背景里聊天，天呐。我懂。就是你和布莱恩在后面闲聊。不，我知道，我知道。其实，我看到这场戏时自己偷偷笑出声了，因为，你知道的，他们在那里站着。所以我们会入镜。他们经常这么干。他们会把我和布莱恩安排在文件柜旁，奥斯卡可以留在他的座位上，因为他在摄像机的视线范围内，但他们必须把布莱恩和我拉出来。所以我们就站在后面的那些文件柜旁。
And you guys, we are just shooting the shiitake. We're just like, you know, just like, oh, hey, do you guys want to grab dinner? Yeah, what's up? And Oscar's job was to be our lookout. Okay. He didn't sign up for this job. We just made him do it. So he went under his breath saying, guys, kind of swing her over, camera swinging over. And then sometimes like suddenly like snap back into character. And then sometimes he wouldn't catch it. And then all of a sudden, Brian, and I would love it if there was one moment during the run of the show that it was on camera, he would flick me, you know, he'd like flick my arm, like, stop talking. That's amazing. We're just, you know, we're just the idiots back there just chatting it up and accounting. Well,
然后你们几个，我们其实就是在瞎扯淡。我们就像是，你知道的，就比如，哦，嘿，你们想不想一起去吃晚饭？行啊，怎么了？而奥斯卡的工作就是替我们把风。好吧。他可没主动要求干这活儿。是我们硬要他这么干的。所以他会压低声音说，伙计们，转过来了，摄像机转过来了。然后有时我们就会突然像触电一样进入角色。但有时他没能及时提醒。然后突然之间，布莱恩，如果剧集播出时有哪怕一个镜头拍到了这一幕，我都会开心得要死，他会弹我一下，你知道的，他会弹我的胳膊，好像在说，别聊了。这太棒了。我们就是，你知道的，就是会计部背景里闲聊的两个白痴。好吧，
speaking of accounting, we have a very strange scene now where Kevin asked Jim, who he thinks is hotter between Karen and Pam. I called this the Kevpervalert. Yeah, Kevin starts listing off all of what he believes to be the various attributes of Karen and Pam. And Jim, Jim is like, eventually he's like, you know what, I think you should take the rest of the day, try to figure this out and get back to me. Well, at five minutes, 37 seconds, you see Jim kind of put his hand up to his chin, like he's considering this. Hmm, right? Hmm, kind of thinking about this. And the DVD commentary, John said that was his Mike Schur impression. That right in that moment, he was being Mike Schur. Yes, that's really good.
说到会计部，我们现在看到了一场非常奇怪的戏，凯文问吉姆他觉得凯伦和帕姆谁更辣。我把这称为“凯文火辣指数评估”。对，凯文开始逐一列举他认为凯伦和帕姆各自的各种吸引力所在。而吉姆，吉姆一开始还听着，最后他说，你知道吗，我觉得你今天剩下的时间都用来好好琢磨这个吧，然后回头再告诉我。好吧，在5分37秒时，你会看到吉姆把手托在下巴上，好像在认真思考。嗯，对吧？嗯，一副在思考这事的样子。在DVD评论音轨中，约翰说那是他在模仿迈克·舒尔。就在那一刻，他在扮演迈克·舒尔。没错，真的很像。
He snuck in an impression in the episode. I love that. So now Pam goes into the break room and you guys, there are more of these scenes where she gets teased, but this one made it in. Oscar teases her and everyone kind of laughs about her big speech she made to Jim. And Stanley's like, it's the most I ever saw you speak. I mean, I thought, is that Kelly? And Kelly's like, no, that was pathetic. Like, that's no, I would never do that. No offense. And then Meredith is like, well, you know what, everyone was drunk. No one remembers that. And Creed goes, oh, I do, I blogged about it. And now we find out that Creed Bratton has a blog. Yes. Ryan explains in a talking head that last year, Creed asked him how to make a blog. But Ryan
他把一段模仿悄悄塞进了这集里。我太喜欢了。所以现在帕姆走进了茶水间，你们知道的，还有更多关于她被调侃的戏份，但只有这场播出了。奥斯卡调侃她，大家都在笑她之前对吉姆发表的长篇大论。斯坦利还说，那是我见你说过最多话的一次。我的意思是，我想，那是凯利吗？凯利则说，不，那太可悲了。就好像，才不是呢，我才不会那样做。无意冒犯。然后梅雷迪思说，好吧，你知道的，当时大家都喝醉了。没人记得这事。结果克里德来了一句，哦，我记得，我在博客上写了。现在我们发现克里德·布拉顿竟然有个博客。是的。瑞安在单独访谈中解释说，去年克里德问他怎么开通博客，但瑞安
just opened up a Word document and told him this was a blog. And he said that he did that in order to protect the world from Creed's thoughts. Yeah, because he said even for the internet, they're pretty scary. So then you see Creed working on his blog. And of course, you guys, I had to screen grab it and see what he wrote. So the top of his blog says www.creedthoughts.gov.www backslashcreedthoughts. And this is what the screen says. Creed Thoughts. Hey, oh, everyone out there in cyber world, cyber spelled with an S. It's old. It's old Creed Bratton coming at you again. So we get to see his last name, which I love Jenna. Yes. Yes. Yeah. So it says it's old Creed Bratton coming at you again here from my perch as a quality
只是打开了一个Word文档，告诉他这就是博客。他还说他这么做是为了保护世界免受克里德思想的荼毒。对，因为他说即使对互联网来说，他的想法也太可怕了。然后你就能看到克里德在写他的博客。当然了，伙计们，我不得不截屏看看他到底写了些什么。所以他博客顶部写着：www.creedthoughts.gov.www斜杠creedthoughts。屏幕上显示的内容是这样的：克里德思想。嘿，哦，网络世界里的各位，网络（cyber）是用S拼的。我是老。老克里德·布拉顿又来找你们了。所以我们看到了他的姓氏，我太喜欢了，珍娜。对。对。对。所以上面写着：我是老克里德·布拉顿，以邓德米弗林纸业公司的质量
assurance manager at Dunder Mifflin paper. Just a few observations on the world around me. What do you guys think is the best kind of car? To me, you can't beat motorcycles. They're small and dangerous. I got into a car and that's all you see. Well, I have to say this. I have to say this to Ryan, fictional character Ryan. I don't think that's so scary. I'm like, why can't Creed blog about he that he likes motorcycles? Well, there obviously is something that we're not seeing. I guess so. Well, we talked to Paul a little bit about this and he mentioned that Jason Kessler, our writer's assistant actually did write for a little over a year, the blog of Creed thoughts for NBC.com. And by the way, if you would like to look for it, you can still find it.
保证经理的身份，再次从我的视角向你们问好。对周围世界的一些观察。大家觉得什么类型的摩托车最好？对我来说，摩托车无可匹敌。它们又小又危险。我坐过一辆汽车，那就只能看到这些了。好吧，我得这么说。我对瑞安，也就是虚构角色瑞安说，我觉得这没那么可怕。我在想，为什么克里德不能写博客说他喜欢摩托车呢？显然有些我们看不到的东西在里面。我想也是吧。好吧，我们跟保罗稍微聊了聊这个，他提到我们的编剧助理杰森·凯斯勒其实真的为NBC.com代笔写了一年多的“克里德思想”博客。顺便说一句，如果你想找来看看，现在还能找到。
It is at blog.nbc.com backslash Creed thoughts. I looked at it. There are so many amazing things. He has a whole story on there about how he stayed late one night at the office and he found a squirrel in Michael's safe. That's one of the stories. Yes. Yes. He says he's so glad that he figured out the combination of Michael's safe because it ended up saving a squirrel's life. He would like to know why Michael put a squirrel in his safe. That's one of his entries. Creed, did you really put it in there and then you forgot about it? It's possible. It's possible. But you can check it out. It's still there. That's so fun. I didn't know it was still active. That's so fun. Well, now Michael visits the accounting department and he's talking about his new job and how he's already sold his condo
网址是blog.nbc.com斜杠Creed thoughts。我看过。里面有太多神奇的内容了。他在上面写了一个完整的故事，讲的是有一天他加班到很晚，在迈克尔的保险箱里发现了一只松鼠。这就是其中一个故事。是的。是的。他说他很高兴自己破解了迈克尔保险箱的密码，因为这最终救了一只松鼠的命。他很想知道迈克尔为什么要把松鼠放进保险箱里。这是他的博文之一。克里德，真的是你把它放进去然后自己忘了吗？有可能。完全有可能。但你们可以去看看。它还在那儿呢。太有趣了。我之前不知道它居然还在运行。太有趣了。好了，现在迈克尔来到会计部，谈起他的新工作，以及他已经把公寓卖了
and they're like, whoa, whoa, whoa. What's what? What? And I love this scene. I remembered when we were doing the scene. At the end of the scene, we improvised all of that. And when I was watching it, I was remembering that. And then I went to the DVD commentary and Ken Quapas said, yeah, he was like, the scene didn't really have an ending. So I just asked the accountants if they would improvise sort of reacting to Michael. And that's how we went out of the scene. I think this scene is such a great example of the three of you as an improvisational trio. You guys work so well off of one another. Your deliveries are spot on. And I noted it when I watched Angela and I went to the script and Ken Quapas is right. It really just ended with Michael
，然后他们就震惊了：哇，哇，哇。什么情况？什么？我太喜欢这场戏了。我记得我们拍这场戏的时候。在戏的结尾，那些全都是我们即兴发挥的。我刚才在看的时候，又想起了这件事。然后我去看了DVD评论音轨，肯·夸帕斯说，对，他说，这场戏其实没有结尾。所以我只是让会计部的几个人即兴对迈克尔的反应做出一些表演。这场戏就是这样收尾的。我觉得这场戏简直是你们三人群戏即兴发挥的绝佳范例。你们三个配合得太天衣无缝了。台词抛接精准到位。我注意到这一点时，我去翻了剧本，肯·夸帕斯说得对。原本剧本真的只是以迈克尔
giving the news that he's already sold his condo on eBay. That was the button. But I think this scene is brilliant because of your reaction. And I'm so glad they left it in. Well, I love that it made it in. And I really loved our little accounting pod. We so clearly knew our characters and how they would react to one another at all times. And we were rarely ever on the same page. But in this moment, all three of us have similar reactions. I say, who gave you that advice? You know, and then Kevin and Oscar all chime in. And for once, the accounting department is all on the same page. Well, we had a fan catch in this that I absolutely love from Adalia L. Who said, you guys have mentioned that Phyllis was constantly looking at fences for her home.
宣布他已经在易趣上卖掉了自己的公寓作为结尾。这就已经是爆点包了。但我觉得这场戏之所以绝妙，全靠你们的反应。我太庆幸他们把这部分剪进去了。哦，我很庆幸它留下来了。而且我真的超爱我们这个会计小组。我们对自己的角色以及他们会如何随时对彼此作出反应简直心知肚明。虽然我们平时很难达成一致。但在这一刻，我们三个人的反应出奇地一致。我说，谁给你的建议？你知道的，然后凯文和奥斯卡也纷纷插话。破天荒地，会计部所有人难得在同一个频道上。好吧，这场戏里有一个我超级喜欢的粉丝发现，来自阿达利亚·L。她说，你们之前提到菲利斯一直在为自己的家看围栏。
Please tell me she caught the fence on her computer at about seven minutes, 20 seconds. I think she's looking at fences on her computer in the background of the scene. Angela, this is amazing. Because you know how you were mentioning that sometimes you would check to see if you were in the background. Yeah. At seven minutes, 10 seconds, Phyllis looks over her shoulder to accounting. And I swear that what she's doing is sneaking a look to see where the camera is. And I think she thinks she's not on camera because right after that, she clicks on a website to look at fences. Yes. That's exactly what she was doing. Yes, it was amazing. You guys, Phyllis looked at fences for like a year. Yeah. Like for months
请告诉我她在7分20秒左右时在电脑上看到围栏了。我觉得在这场戏的背景里，她在电脑上浏览围栏呢。安吉拉，这太神了。因为你知道你之前提到过，有时你会确认自己有没有入镜。对。在7分10秒时，菲利斯回头朝会计部看了一眼。我发誓她那是在偷偷看摄像机在哪儿。而且我觉得她以为自己没入镜，因为紧接着她就点开了一个网站开始看围栏。没错。她当时就是在干这个。对，太绝了。伙计们，菲利斯看了一整年的围栏。对。连续几个月
and months. And we would, you know, she would want our opinion and we'd go over and we'd look at fences with her. Yeah. So many. It was great. So many fences. Well, now, Angela, speaking of scenes that I just absolutely love. This next one with Dwight and Angela in the kitchen. And Dwight is telling Angela about his new promotion. He is going to have Michael's job. Oh, it's so good. It's so good. It's one of these Shakespearean moments between Dwight and Angela. Very Macbeth, right? Yes. And once again, they're not facing each other, you know? So Angela doesn't even see his face. And at the end, Angela, you say goodbye, Kelly Kapoor. Oh, yeah. And that was not in the script, lady. I know. I know. So I got to improvise a little bit right there. And my memory
几个月都在看。我们会，你知道的，她会征求我们的意见，然后我们就会过去和她一起看围栏。对。看了好多。太棒了。看了超级多围栏。好吧，现在，安吉拉，说到我极其喜欢的戏份。接下来这场是德怀特和安吉拉在厨房里的戏。德怀特正在跟安吉拉讲他的新晋升。他要接替迈克尔的工作了。哦，太棒了。真的太棒了。这是德怀特和安吉拉之间极具莎士比亚风格的时刻。很有《麦克白》的感觉，对吧？是的。而且他们俩又双双背对着彼此，你知道吗？所以安吉拉甚至看不到他的表情。到最后，安吉拉，你说了一句：再见，凯利·卡普尔。哦，对。那可不是剧本里的，亲爱的。
is that I improvised that. And when I listened to the DVD commentary, Dave Rogers said, I'm pretty sure Angela improvised that line. So I just figured she would just be consumed with her own power. And, you know, Dwight has said if he, if he takes over, she gets to be in charge of the women. So it's sort of a callback. And, you know, Kelly Kapoor has been on her list for a long time. Well, I think this is also a callback to product recall. I think that Kelly went to the top of Angela's list after she had to sit through that customer service training. Well, no doubt. No doubt. She tried to kiss Dwight at a Christmas party. And then there was Diwali and then product recall. So Angela's like, see you later, Kelly Kapoor. Yeah. Who's next on Angela's list?
我知道。我知道。所以我当时就稍微即兴发挥了一下。我的记忆是，那是我即兴加的。当我听DVD评论音轨时，戴夫·罗杰斯说，我敢肯定那句台词是安吉拉即兴发挥的。所以我当时就觉得她应该完全被自己的权力欲冲昏了头脑。而且，你知道的，德怀特说过如果他接管公司，她就能管女员工。所以这算是一个前情呼应。而且，你知道的，凯利·卡普尔在她的黑名单上待很久了。嗯，我觉得这也是对《产品召回》那一集的呼应。我觉得自从安吉拉不得不忍受那场客户服务培训后，凯利就直接飙升到她黑名单榜首了。毫无疑问。毫无疑问。她竟然在圣诞派对上试图吻德怀特。然后还有排灯节，接着又是产品召回。所以安吉拉的心态就是：回头见，凯利·卡普尔。对。下一个上安吉拉黑名单的是谁？
The list is long, lady. The list is long. Is it Kevin? Maybe Kevin. Oh, for sure. For sure. And maybe she gets her way in the finale just saying, okay, we're not there yet. Okay. Well, in the scene, Dwight and Angela have this really fun couplet of dialogue. Dwight says, how would you like to spend the night with a regional manager of Dunder Mifflin Scranton? And Angela goes, no Dwight. And I don't care if that's how they consolidated power in ancient Rome. And he's like, I mean me. Well, listen, lady, I think maybe we should take a break. And when we come back, we're going to see what this new power does to Dwight. Oh, well, get ready. Get ready for his bed and breakfast and hell. All right, we'll be right back. All right, we are back. And
名单很长呢，亲爱的。名单长得很。是凯文吗？也许是凯文。哦，绝对是。肯定的。说不定在大结局里她如愿以偿了，我是说，好吧，我们还没看到那儿呢。好吧，在这场戏里，德怀特和安吉拉有一段非常有趣的对话。德怀特说：你愿不愿意和邓德米弗林斯克兰顿分公司的地区经理共度良宵？安吉拉则说：才不要，德怀特。我才不管古代罗马是不是这样巩固权力的呢。然后他说：我是指我。好吧，听着，亲爱的，我觉得我们也许该休息一下。等我们回来，就会看到这种新权力会把德怀特变成什么样。哦，那就拭目以待吧。准备好迎接他的“地狱汽车旅馆”吧。好，我们马上回来。好的，我们回来了。
Dwight is taunting Jim about his new position at Hotel Hill. And he's doing one of those hand, um, what are they called? Those hand exerciser things. What are those for? Why am I exercising my hand? So your grip gets really strong. So I can hold heavier weights while I'm lifting weights. Is that what that's for? Or maybe, what do I need a strong hand for? Maybe, maybe if you wrestle, you can grab someone and hold real tight. I don't know. I don't, I've never understood why I would want my hands to be super muscularly. Muscularly muscular. I feel like, I feel like my husband has one. And um, I know, I know with baking, like he's needing all kinds of dough and bread and doing stuff. And I feel like, I feel like he's got roll strong hands. Oh, wow, do I need one of those?
德怀特正在就吉姆在“地狱酒店”的新职位对吉姆进行冷嘲热讽。他手里还在做那个，呃，那叫什么来着？那个手部锻炼器。那玩意儿到底是干嘛用的？我为什么要锻炼手部力量？为了让握力变得超级强。这样我在举重时就能拿更重的哑铃。那是干这个用的吗？或者说，我为什么需要一双强壮的手呢？也许，也许如果你去摔跤，你就能抓住别人并死死抱住。我不知道。我从来不理解为什么我希望自己的手变成肌肉发达的肌肉怪。肌肉发达。肌肉发达。我觉得，我觉得我丈夫就有一个。而且，我知道，在烘焙的时候，他需要揉各种面团和面包之类的东西。我觉得，我觉得他有一双灵活有力的手。哦，哇，我也需要一个那样的东西吗？
Maybe so that I can need my dough better. Maybe then you'd have like super dough needing strength. Hmm. Anyway, maybe I, maybe I should ask for one for Christmas. Dwight is doing this throughout this whole ridiculous, I don't even know what it is, a dream or fantasy of his, of this insane hotel hell. And then Jim just takes him to task so calmly. He's like, wait, wait, you're the manager. You don't, this is your fantasy. You don't even own it. And he's like, I go own it with Satan. Yeah. And he's like, I just want to make sure I'm clear that your wildest fantasy has you as the co-owner of a bed and breakfast with Satan in hell. And, but you only make $80,000 a year. Oh yeah. Dwight's like, wait, wait, wait, I haven't told you the best part. Yeah. The best
也许这样我就能更好地揉面团了？也许那样你就会拥有超强的揉面力量。嗯。不管怎样，也许我，也许我应该要一个作为圣诞礼物。德怀特一直在他这整个荒谬的幻想中喋喋不休，我甚至不知道那是什么，他的梦想还是幻想，关于这个疯狂的地狱酒店。然后吉姆就非常冷静地反驳了他。吉姆说，等等，等等，你是经理。你不需要，这只是你的幻想。你甚至都不是老板。结果他说：我和撒旦共同拥有它。对。然后吉姆说：我只想确认一下，你最疯狂的幻想竟然是和撒旦在烈火地狱里合伙经营一家B&B民宿。而且你一年才挣八万美元。哦，对。德怀特就像是，等等，等等，我还没告诉你最棒的部分呢。对，最棒的
part, I make $80,000 a year. Now Jenna, so here's the thing. I, I saw online that fans of the office were like, you know, if you divide 80,000 by 12, you get like 6666.66667 or something like that. And I was like, oh my God, do the writers do that on purpose? They must have. They must have. Well, what a brilliant little layer they gave that then. We had a lot of people writing about that. Rebecca Womack, Beth Jones, and Paulina J. and Jake Moss all also noticed that $80,000 a year is $6,666.66. That's pretty cool. I mean, that's, I mean, I like little details like that. I think that's fun. You know, if that were my salary, I think I would be a little bit weirded out. I don't think I would want to have a salary. I wouldn't want to get checks. I mean, I guess you take out
部分是，我一年能赚八万美元。珍娜，事情是这样的。我，我在网上看到《办公室》的粉丝们说，你知道的，如果你把8万除以12，你会得到大约6666.66667之类的数字。然后我就想，哦天哪，编剧是故意的吗？他们一定是故意的。一定是这样的。哇，他们给这个细节赋予了多么绝妙的暗喻啊。有很多人给我们写信提到这个。丽贝卡·沃马克、贝丝·琼斯、保利娜·J.和杰克·莫斯也都注意到了，年薪八万美元正好等于每月6666.66美元。太酷了。我的意思是，我喜欢这样的小细节。我觉得这很有趣。你知道，如果那是我的薪水，我想我可能会觉得有点瘆得慌。我想我不会愿意拿这样的薪水。我甚至不想收到这样的支票。我的意思是，我猜扣除
the taxes and everything. Your check wouldn't really say that, but even still in my mind, I think it would weird me out because do you know what I had for a very long time? What? I had a credit card and you know, you have your little three digit secret code. My secret code was 666. Oh, no, no, no, I'd say get that away. I'm not having any of that. I would be on the phone trying to buy something like let's say I'm ordering a pizza and they'd be like, what's your credit card number? And they'd be like, and the security code. And I would always be like, it's 666. And what would they say? People would be like, what? They would laugh. And I'd always have to be like, I know, I know. And I wanted to like, just intentionally get rid
税费和各种杂费之后。你的支票上其实不会写那个数字，但即便如此，我心里还是会觉得毛骨悚然，因为你知道我用了很久的东西是什么吗？什么？我有一张信用卡，你知道的，上面有三位数的小秘密代码。我的安全码就是666。哦，不，不，不，我会说快拿走那个。我才不要那玩意儿呢。我以前打电话想买东西时，比如说我正在订披萨，他们就会问：您的信用卡号是多少？然后他们会说：还有安全码。我就会总是回答：是666。然后他们会说什么？人们就会说：啊？他们会笑。而我总是不得不解释说：我知道，我知道。我当时就想，故意把
of this card so they would issue me a new one. Oh, no, that's not my security code anymore. But I imagine that's like layered because it's like, on the one hand, that's creepy. It's creepy. And then you have to say these creepy numbers. But then you also now have chitty chat when you just want to order your pizza. Now that person's hearing it for the first time. So they're like, Oh my God, that's weird. Yeah, I know. Oh, are you going to change it? I'm going to try. But like over and over for two years, two years. Well, then Dwight has a talking head. He says his first order of business will be to demote Jim, which means he will need a new number two. His first choice would be Jack Bauer. Yeah, you know, from 24. But he's fictional and unavailable.
这张卡注销掉，好让他们给我补办一张新的。哦，不，那不再是我的安全码了。但我能想象那就像是叠加了buff，因为一方面，这很诡异。太诡异了。然后你还得大声说出这些诡异的数字。但同时，你现在只是想订个披萨，还得经历这种尬聊。现在对方是第一次听到这个。所以他们会想：哦天哪，这也太怪了吧。对，我懂。哦，你打算换掉它吗？我尽量。但就这么反反复复持续了两年，整整两年。好吧，接着德怀特有一段个人访谈。他说他的头等大事就是降职吉姆，这意味着他需要一个新的二把手。他的首选是杰克·鲍尔。对，你知道的，就是《24小时》里的那个。但他是虚构人物，而且没空。
This was a nod to Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant. How so? They loved 24. Love 24. They were obsessed with it. They both got cameos on 24. I went, yes, and I watched them. So Ricky Gervais was in the sixth season. His scene did not make it, but you can find it online. And I guess it's on like the DVD box set or something. And he's having this comedic moment in the Oval Office. It's totally random because you know, 24 is such a drama. The stakes are so high. But he's in the background with his longtime girlfriend, Jane Fallon. They got to be in the show. And then later on, Stephen Merchant makes a brief appearance. He doesn't have a speaking role, but he's a CTU worker. He wasn't credited on the episode, but he is there. He's in the background
这是向瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特致敬。怎么说？他们超级喜欢《24小时》。太喜欢《24小时》了。他们简直对它痴迷至极。他们俩都在《24小时》里客串过。我去，是的，我还看了。所以瑞奇·热维斯出现在第六季里。他的戏份虽然被剪掉了，但你可以在网上找到。我猜它应该在DVD套装或者别的什么地方。他在椭圆形办公室里有一段喜剧表演。这完全是随机的，因为你知道，《24小时》是一部正剧。剧情极其紧张。但他在背景里，和交往多年的女友简·法伦一起。他们得以在剧里露脸。后来，斯蒂芬·莫昌特也短暂出场了。他没有台词，但他是个CTU（反恐局）的工作人员。他在这一集里没有演员署名，但他确实在那儿。他就出现在
when they cut to CTU. So he made it in. He made it in. He has no lines, but he made it in. But I guess this little reference to Jack Bauer from Dwight was a little nod to Ricky and Stephen from the writers. I love that. Well, now something major happens. Two major things happen. Jan shows up at the office unannounced. And we talked about this scene a little bit with Paul, where Jan and Michael are standing at reception with Pam between them. And Michael is trying so hard to have boundaries. Oh, I loved it when she walked in and he goes, why are you here? And Malora is being that very, very scary, sane version of a crazy person. Oh, for sure. Like in the horror movies, right before they turn on you. Yeah. No,
镜头切到CTU时的背景里。所以他成功出镜了。他成功出镜了。虽然没有台词，但他确实出现了。不过我猜德怀特对杰克·鲍尔的这个小彩蛋，是编剧们向瑞奇和斯蒂芬致敬的小心意。我太喜欢了。好吧，接下来发生了一件大事。两件大事发生了。简毫无预兆地出现在办公室里。我们之前跟保罗稍微聊过这场戏，简和迈克尔站在前台旁，帕姆夹在他们中间。迈克尔极力想要划清界限。哦，我太喜欢她走进来时他说的那句：你为什么在这儿？而马洛拉把那个疯狂之人的那种非常非常可怕、看似理智的版本演得淋漓尽致。哦，绝对的。就像恐怖电影里，他们在对你翻脸之前的那一刻。对。
it's that moment where you're like, hi, lovely. And then it's like, ha. Yes. Like you're wondering, wait, are they a cyborg? Yeah. I made you coffee, honey. With a knife. Yes. Yes. Yes. Super creepy. She goes into his office and Michael is like, I need all my ladies. Def content. In the conference room. Def content, Pam. Immediately. Except Meredith, who's an alternate. Yeah. Well, so now Pam has to go tell everybody, right? So she goes up to Karen and she's like, hey, Michael needs us. Jan's here. He's freaking out. And Karen is so passive aggressive in this moment. She's like, okay. Listen, before we leave, would you make, you know, copies of our sales reports? Would you go make some copies? Would you photocopy some stuff for me? Oh, and for my
不，就是那种让你觉得：嗨，亲爱的，然后紧接着就是：哈。没错。就好像你在纳闷：等等，他们该不会是个生化人吧？对。我给你煮了咖啡，亲爱的。手里还拿了把刀。是的。是的。是的。超级诡异。她走进了他的办公室，迈克尔就说：我要我所有的女士们。一级战备。全都到会议室去。一级战备，帕姆。马上。除了梅雷迪思，她是替补。好吧，所以现在帕姆得去通知所有人，对吧？于是她走到凯伦面前说：嘿，迈克尔找我们。简来了。他快抓狂了。而凯伦在这个时候表现得超级被动攻击。她说：好的。听着，在我们离开之前，你能把我们的销售报告复印一下吗？你能去复印一下吗？你能帮我复印点东西吗？哦，还有为我的
boyfriend whom I'm about to go to New York with for the night. Will you make us some photocopies? That's the subtext. Yeah. I know. I'm just gonna, I'm gonna take a minute and I'm gonna put you in your place, misreceptionist. Yeah, she does. That's true. And then though, Pam, Pam, leaning hard into this new, like I'm gonna say stuff when I want to say it looks right at her and goes, I hope you get the job. Yeah. Little Pam's ass. I want your ass out of here. I'll make your copies. I want your ass gone. I'll make you 12 copies. How about that? You can shove them where the sun don't shine. Okay. So Jan explains to Michael, she gives her plea. She says that after their breakup, she went on vacation. Another vacation. Yeah. But she's made some big changes and she really,
男朋友，也就是今晚我要一起去纽约的那个男朋友。你能帮我们复印几份吗？这就是潜台词。对。我知道。我得花上一分钟，好好杀杀你的威风，前台小姐。对，她确实这么做了。不过紧接着，帕姆，帕姆狠狠地顺应了这种新状态，也就是“老娘想说什么就说什么”，她直视着凯伦说：祝你面试顺利。对。小帕姆反击了。我巴不得你赶紧滚蛋呢。复印就复印。我巴不得你快消失。我给你复印12份都行。怎么样？有本事你把它们塞到太阳照不到的地方去。好吧。于是简向迈克尔解释，她为自己辩解了一番。她说在他们分手后，她去度假了。又去度假了。对。但她做出了一些重大改变，她真的、
really misses him. And she wants to get back together. Michael runs out of the office and into the conference room. Defcon 20. And all the women in the conference room are like, Michael, no, do not get back together with her. You have to stay strong. She doesn't make you happy. We are, we're good. We all agree. Michael's like, yes. Yeah. So now he feels empowered. He's going to go in and tell Jan, no, no, we are not getting back together. But he walks back in his office and Jan has taken off her jacket to reveal that she has had breast augmentation surgery. She is wearing a white, very tight little knit sweater with a plunging neckline. Yep. And she's got a bodacious set of tatas.
真的是想念他。她想复合。迈克尔吓得冲出办公室，跑进会议室。二级战备。会议室里的所有女同胞都在说：迈克尔，不，千万别和她复合。你得立场坚定。她根本带给你快乐。我们，我们都挺好的。大家意见一致。迈克尔说：没错。对。所以现在他信心满满。他要进去告诉简，不，不，我们不会复合的。但他刚走回办公室，简就脱掉了夹克，露出了她做了隆胸手术的事实。她穿着一件白色、非常紧身的针织小毛衣，领口开得很低。没错。她拥有一对波涛汹涌的豪乳。
She does. That are like, hello in his eyes. He, he walks in. He's like, what? My gosh. Because he's such an adolescent. He cannot take his eyes off her chest and she knows it. This is going to appeal to Michael. Absolutely. Absolutely. She knew what she was doing. Well, we had some people ask, did Malora get a breast augmentation for this episode? No. No, she didn't. They designed this crazy bra for her that was filled with like a gazillion little cutlets. And then they did this like makeup shadowing on her chest to create even more illusion of like swollen cleavage and all of that. And I do remember poor Malora from this point forward would have to put that on for every episode now. I listened to the DVD commentary and Ken
确实有。简直像是在他眼前直晃悠。他，他走进去。整个人惊呆了：什么？我的天。因为他实在太像个青春期男孩了。他的目光根本无法从她的胸口移开，而她心知肚明。这招对迈克尔绝对管用。绝对的。绝对的。她很清楚自己在干什么。好吧，有人问过我们：马洛拉是为了这一集专门去隆胸了吗？并没有。并没有。他们为她设计了一个疯狂的胸罩，里面塞了成吨的小衬垫。然后他们还在她的胸口化了那种阴影妆，来营造出更加夸张的、乳沟饱满的视觉效果，诸如此类。我还记得可怜的马洛拉从这一集开始，以后每拍一集都得戴上那个东西。我看过DVD评论音轨，肯·
Quapas and Malora were part of this commentary. And they said they had a meeting to discuss her boop job storyline with Greg. So it was Ken, Malora and Greg. And they really had a like earnest conversation about what size they would be. Like how big would Jan go and how much of a visual joke would this be? And Malora said this whole storyline was just a lot of fun, but they just, it was just a really fun thing for her character and just part of that journey that Paul was talking about of Jan really starting this spiral. And she did say that for a long time people would come up to her and ask if those boobs were hers. Oh, I know poor Malora. Poor Malora. Oh my gosh. Well, it works. Michael gets back together with Jan.
夸帕斯和马洛拉都参与了那段评论。他们说他们开过一个会，和格雷格讨论她的“胸部”剧情线。所以当时在场的有肯、马洛拉和格雷格。他们非常认真地讨论了到底应该做多大尺寸。比如简的胸应该做多大，这个视觉笑话能达到什么效果？马洛拉说整条剧情线拍起来非常有意思，但对她的角色来说，这确实是一段极其好玩的经历，也是保罗之前谈到的简开始彻底失控的那段旅程的一部分。她确实说过，很长一段时间里都会有人走过来问她那些胸是不是她自己的。哦，我知道，可怜的马洛拉。可怜的马洛拉。哦天哪。不过这招确实管用。迈克尔和简复合了。
He says it was not for the boobs. No, it wasn't for the boobs. No, of course not. But he said that would be shallow. And this is actually emotionally magnificent. Yeah. So yeah, he's going to give this relationship another try. Yeah. Well, Jan walks out into the bullpen. Oh, by the way, I can't believe I forgot to bring this up. In the very beginning when she shows up, Michael goes, Janet. And I was like, what? I forgot. Her name was Janet. It is? Yes. When she enters the office and I'm sorry to take us back a minute, he says, hello, Janet. And I'm like, Janet, that's my sister's name. And but is that just Michael doing Michael? No, no, I looked it up. Her character's name is Janet. And her nickname
他说这不是因为胸。不，不是因为胸。不，当然不是。但他觉得如果是那样就太肤浅了。而这实际上是情感上的震撼。所以，是的，他打算再给这段感情一次机会。好吧，简走到了大办公区。哦，顺便说一句，我简直不敢相信我居然忘了提这个。最开始她出现的时候，迈克尔说：珍妮特。当时我的反应是：什么？我都忘了。她的名字叫珍妮特。是吗？是的。当她走进办公室时，不好意思让我把时间倒回一分钟，他说：你好，珍妮特。我的反应是：珍妮特，那是我姐姐的名字。但，这只是迈克尔在发挥他那套迈克尔式的作风吗？不，不，我查过了。她角色的名字就叫珍妮特。而她的昵称
is Jan. Wow. Yes. Wow. Mm hmm. There you go. Janet Levinson. Gold. Drop the gold. She's not with gold anymore. No. And so she walks into the bullpen and now everyone sees her new boobs and everyone is having their reactions. You know, Meredith is like, waste of money. I find that guys are way more interested in the back of you than the front in her experience. And I thought Kate did such a great job with that talking head. She just throws that line away. She doesn't put too much on it. Yeah. And she did a brilliant job. And Pam, once again, when trying to flirt with Jim, it's like, Oh my God, they're so big. And he's like, I know, she's just trying to flirt. She's trying to flirt. She wants to be friends again. She's
是简。哇。是的。哇。嗯哼。原来如此。珍妮特·莱文森。戈德。把戈德去掉了。她不再跟戈德在一起了。没有。于是她走进了大办公区，现在所有人都看到了她崭新的大胸，每个人都作出了各自的反应。你知道的，梅雷迪思说：简直是浪费钱。根据她的经验，她发现男人对你的背面远比正面感兴趣。我觉得凯特在这段单人访谈里表现得太棒了。她随口就把这句台词抛出来了。她没有用力过猛。对。她表现得极其出色。而帕姆，再次在试图跟吉姆调情时说：哦天哪，它们太大了。而吉姆则说：我知道，她只是在调情。她就是在调情。她想重新做朋友。她表现得很
being friendly. She wants to be friends with benefits. Well, she wants to be more than friends. Yeah. While everyone is reacting to the boobs, we have another pretty big storyline, which is Dwight is going to start interviewing his new number two. And the only person who signed up was Andy. Yes, which leads to this amazing interview scene between Dwight and Andy. It's like a rapid fire Q&A session. Yes. And it's so great. We had a fan question from Seth Jason Tan and Zhu Yi Wang. How much of the dialogue between Andy and Dwight was scripted when Dwight is interviewing him for assistant to the regional manager? Well, guys, everything you see in the episode was scripted, but there was so much more in the script. Angela, is that stuff in the deleted
友善。她想发展成“纯友谊之上”的关系。好吧，她想做的不只是朋友。就在所有人都在对胸部做出反应时，我们迎来了另一条相当重要的剧情线，那就是德怀特要开始面试他的新二把手了。而唯一报名的人居然是安迪。没错，这就引发了德怀特和安迪之间这场精彩绝伦的面试戏。这就像是一场快节奏的问答连环炮。是的。太精彩了。我们收到了来自赛斯、杰森·陈和朱怡王的粉丝提问：当德怀特在面试地区经理助理时，安迪和德怀特之间的台词有多少是剧本写好的？好吧，伙计们，你们在剧集里看到的一切都是剧本里有的，但剧本里其实还有更多内容。安吉拉，那些内容在被删减
scenes? Because it was so funny on the page. There are great deleted scenes, Jenna, from this scene. And apparently there's even more that we're not even getting to see on the DVDs. I listened to the DVD commentary and they said these guys went on and on and on. And then they went past the scripted stuff and they just started improvising. And Ken Kuapa said Rain was just throwing the craziest stuff at Ed and Ed did not miss a beat. Like, all right, walk me through an appendectomy. And Ed, as Andy, is like, all right, you sterilize the area. You make an incision. They're great deleted scenes on the DVD, but I think there's even more that we don't get to see. It was amazing. I absolutely loved it. And Dwight has no choice. This is his only choice.
片段里吗？因为剧本纸面上看起来太搞笑了。有很棒的被删减片段，珍娜，就是这场戏的。而且显然还有更多甚至都没能在DVD里播出的内容。我听了DVD评论音轨，他们说这俩人当时聊个没完没了。然后他们演完了剧本内容，直接开始即兴发挥。肯·夸帕斯说雷恩当时一直在抛出各种最疯狂的梗给埃德，而埃德完全对答如流。比如：好吧，带我走一遍阑尾切除术的流程。而埃德饰演的安迪就说：好的，你先对患处进行消毒。然后切开切口。DVD里有很棒的被删减片段，但我猜还有更多我们看不到的内容。太惊艳了。我简直爱惨了。而且德怀特别无选择。这是他唯一的选择。
Which is so great. Well, we're going to end this part one of the job with Michael finally leaving for his interview. He is holding Jan's breasts. Well, they've shut the blinds, but they've only shut them on one side of his office. They left him open on the other side. And so the camera gets this little, I used to call it a peep shot. That's not what it's called. Sneaky shot, spy view, sneak, spy, spy shot. You got it. You got there. A spy shot. I found it. I got there. Thanks for sticking with me. Michael's just cupping them. He's just holding them. He's like so happy. Just holding them in his hands. And then he has this crazy talking head where he says two weeks ago he was in the worst relationship of his life. And now he's in the best relationship
太棒了。好吧，我们要迎来“工作”这部分的尾声了，迈克尔终于出发去参加面试了。他正抓着简的胸。好吧，他们把百叶窗拉上了，但只拉上了办公室的一侧。另一侧还敞开着。所以摄像机就拍到了这个小小的，我以前管它叫偷窥镜头。不对，不叫这个。鬼祟镜头、间谍视角、偷、间谍、间谍镜头。对啦。你答对了。间谍镜头。我找到了。我猜对了。谢谢你们陪我一起猜。迈克尔正把双手拢在上面。他正抓着它们。他高兴得不得了。就这么捧在手里。然后他有一段极其疯狂的个人访谈，他说两周前他还在经历人生中最糟糕的恋爱。而现在他正经历人生中最好的恋爱，
of his life with the same woman. Isn't love a mystery? Angela, I mean, can you get a breast augmentation and heal from it in only two weeks? Is that enough time? I know. I thought she was gone longer too. It seemed like to me they hadn't been dating for quite some time because he had thought there was a bigger passage of time. I do too. Because when he walks over to accounting, he's like, I haven't talked to Jan in ages, right? Well, I know that women's appreciation was two episodes ago. But I thought there was more time in real life that had passed. So that bumped me when he said two weeks. I was like, wait, what? And also like, I just would think her boobs would still be so sore. I mean, I don't know. Should I look it up? I think this was maybe a continuity
对象还是同一个人。爱情难道不是个未解之谜吗？安吉拉，我是说，一个人做完隆胸手术能在短短两周内就恢复吗？时间够吗？我知道。我之前也以为她离开的时间更久呢。在我看来，他们好像已经很久没约会了，因为我以为中间过去了一段较长的时间。我也是！因为当他走到会计部时，他说：我好久没跟简说话了，对吧？好吧，我知道“妇女欣赏日”是两集前的事。但我以为现实生活中过去的时间更多一些。所以当他说两周时，我整个人一愣。我在想：等等，什么？而且还有，我觉得她的胸应该还是会超级痛吧。我是说，不知道。我需要去查一下吗？我觉得这可能是一个连贯性错误
error in writing. But I think he said a longer passage of time when he went to accounting. Well, according to PlasticSurgery.org, most surgeons agree that full recovery can take an average of six weeks or so, but that many women notice they feel fine after about only one week. So there you go. But I still think this is a continuity error because of what he said in accounting. I think so too. Well, Michael goes to Pam and he says, Pam, you gave me great advice, but Jan's was bigger. Yeah. Jan's advice was bigger. So Michael's gonna say his goodbyes. You know, he really believes that he's leaving for the very last time. He believes he's gonna go to this interview and get a job at corporate and he and Jan are gonna live happily ever after.
写得有漏洞。但我觉得他在去会计部门时说的是更长的时间。嗯，根据 PlasticSurgery.org 的说法，大多数外科医生一致认为完全康复平均需要大约六周左右，但许多女性注意到大约一周后她们就感觉好多了。所以就是这样。但我仍然认为这是一个连续性错误，因为他在会计部门说过的话。我也这么认为。嗯，迈克尔去找帕姆，对她说，帕姆，你给我的建议很好，但简的胸部更大。是的，简的建议更大。所以迈克尔要告别了。你知道，他真的相信这是他最后一次离开。他相信他要去参加这次面试，并在总公司得到一份工作，他和简将过上幸福快乐的生活。
He sold his condo. The man is leaving in his mind. He plays exit music and he bids everybody a good night and a good luck. Yes. He plays Natalie Merchant on a tiny little tape recorder. And after he leaves Dwight slaps his name on the door and says who's ready to work. And guess who's smiling? Oh, she's so happy. This is a big moment for them. This is a big moment. Well, we will end there for this week. Next week, we will keep breaking down this episode. Jim, Karen and Michael will all arrive in New York for their interviews. Dwight fully takes over Dunder Mifflin with Pam as his secret assistant to the regional manager. Oh, yeah. That's all next week. Oh, yeah. It's a good one, guys. Thank you so much for listening in. And thank you, Paul
他卖掉了他的公寓。在他心里，这个人要走了。他播放离场音乐，向大家道晚安，祝大家好运。是的。他在一个极小的录音机里播放娜塔莉·麦商特的歌。在他离开后，德怀特把他的名字拍在门上，说谁准备好工作了。你猜谁在笑？哦，她太高兴了。对他们来说，这是一个重大时刻。这是一个重大时刻。好吧，我们这周就到这里。下周，我们将继续剖析这一集。吉姆、卡伦和迈克尔都将抵达纽约参加面试。德怀特全面接管邓德米夫林，帕姆担任他秘密的地区经理助理。哦，是的。这一切都在下周。哦，是的。这是一个精彩的节目，伙计们. 非常感谢你们的收听。谢谢你，保罗
Leverstein for being our guest. We will see you next week with job number two. It's a date. It's a date. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Errol, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubacow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
莱弗斯坦作为我们的嘉宾。我们下周见，继续第二部分面试。不见不散。不见不散。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由厄尔、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用 StitcherPremium 一个月，请使用代码 Office。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。